I've paid the price and I'm still paying
the price in a lot of ways it was a good
life lesson for me southern charms
Ashley Jacobs sitting down exclusively
with ET to say her piece about her time
on the show how many times did you visit
your son that was whoa dude that was
don't bring up the kids please if you're
not scared about so you should be you
should be really scared dubbed the
villain got your claws out now
do you handle that label how do I handle
the villain I took it personally to be
honest with you I started to think you
know what did where did I go wrong and
what could I have done differently I can
certainly be blunt and I can certainly
uh I have I have a sharp tongue and I
know how that can be misconstrued but I
did say some hurtful things there were
some things but I wish it could take
back what would you say is the number
one regret in all of this oh my gosh
regret saying those things to Katherine
I might have felt that way but that
wasn't that wasn't the time or place
that wasn't that wasn't the way to do it
you're not a family
we are a found your baby mama it go by
nothing but an egg donor have you gotten
the chance to tell her that you're sorry
you'll have to stay tuned yes there's
more Ashley - come on season six after
her much-anticipated appearance in
episode 9 don't realize it it really was
on a whim you know Eliza vitami to a
party and she said that if you want to
try this might be the this might be your
only opportunity there's an optimist
and some people say I'm delusional for
thinking that way but I always think how
would I want someone to treat me so I
thought maybe they're gonna put
themselves in my position and you know
just listen to me I wanted a chance to
try to make things right I didn't want
to look back and say what if I can look
back and say no I tried I wish it would
have gone differently but I really think
that I didn't have a chance and I think
that's the best way to put it okay yes I
really didn't have a chance to make it
right you can't sit here and call these
people who are closest [ __ ] or
whatever you want to call them and
expect this so we'll be nice to you
what's wrong with your friend that she
can't be nice to me I never want to be
my friend to begin with that's the truth
but I got myself I dug myself deep grave
that I just thought I have to try to let
them understand yeah I definitely get
myself in some trouble with the words
that I you know I use and because of
social media you can't escape why did
you tweet the other week and say that we
were all losers in this person so
well you are horrible a horrible person
that would be my luck that you know just
a few weeks after me making that comment
that I go to the party so I was screwed
but I didn't know they knew about this
comment I wish when that came up they
called us losers I wish one of them had
said what what led you to feel that way
you know why did you feel that way um so
they could better understand I'm not
saying that I'm right I'm just saying
that you know I appealing to and I
reacted I do need you to clarify
something that happened analyzes what is
the difference between keep your mouth
shut okay I don't want to talk about
what happened the past that has nothing
to do with you
we're talking about us would you admit
that sometimes your delivery is not the
best especially in these it's a very
towards okay yeah yeah every day ask my
family ask my friends through all this
what do you think the biggest
misconception is about you I'm evil I'm
psychotic that I that I you know need
mental help I mean I did I got some help
for you know the situational depression
I did but I had nobody I had no support
are you still with Thomas what not I'll
dive right into it she's always some up
worst year of my life maybe I need a
cocktail first you say the last year of
my life has been the worst year of my
life but why did you feel that way I
wasn't in a good place
I'd say myself and then you add a tough
relationship you add his drama with the
mother of his children and I mean that's
a hard situation going just in general
with anyone I would just say it was
extremely lonely because I didn't have
the support of my family
they were very disappointed in my
decision and so the only person we had
was miss Thomas it was dark and it was
really lonely and I wasn't taking care
of myself mentally and the more I tried
to control that or wish things were
different ly the worst more of a toll it
took on me so that's why it was the
worst year I just wish people could sort
of put their themselves and in my
position is there anything else you want
to say before you wrap things up here I
have a story to tell the truth always
rises to the top it could take a few
months it could take a year could take
two years but it will come out I'm gonna
be able to tell people I told you so
okay yes I'm gonna go say I told you so
[Music]